[Music]
for those of you who don't know the
spike tv used is it still around hell no
bro spike tv was a network that lasted
for a few years that was meant to be
like
for guys just for dudes it was for dudes
it was if dane cook was a tv network
yeah kinda yeah so they had a guy's
choice awards you've probably seen clips
of this i feel like this has definitely
made its rounds before but you know it's
never a bad time to revisit what were
these spike tv categories
oh yeah the categories were hottest hole
no way stop yeah sexiest slit no
okay biggest ass kicker gerard butler in
300. yo this is a [ __ ] throwback
hottest girl on the planet beyonce
versus adriana lima i remember her
adriana lima wow that's a name i heard
in a minute bro luckiest bastard and we
already know what that category meant is
you are the luckiest guy by virtue of
who you are dating or with yeah because
you're ugly as [ __ ] this this is
actually super wild yeah sasha baron
cohen no no the next the next category
was funniest mf yeah it's almost like an
ai trying to please men from 2007. yeah
it's a it's a parody of like what like
what a man is naughtiest cyber vixen yo
look up christine dolce who is she was
she that's such a good i
i would you know is that is that
basically an uh pg way of saying porn
star oh yeah she does look like a
naughty cyber vixen the next category is
coolest geek and i thought it was
coolest greek
there's a meal in there do we have any
like clips from like some of these
interviews the interviews is where it
was at man hey i'm kristen reeves here
wait positive
look at who sponsored the guy's choice
awards yeah yeah go army and a t the
army the [ __ ] army
it's funny like even until now whoever
like the us army hires through their
marketing they just don't do a good job
they have a twitch channel
and they would have
like
us phone operators no yeah yeah
what's up we're attacking [ __ ] some
village in yemen today i don't know they
just give me coordinates
wait what were you gonna say they do on
their twitch channel no like it'll just
be a dude on there who's like held
hostage to it it'd be like yo what is up
guys i am sergeant this and that or
private you know smith and today i'm
gonna be playing [ __ ] fall guys and
all the chat will be like what are you
what are your thoughts on like the war
crimes of like the 2007
operation it'll be some [ __ ] grunt
who
you know they just picked out of the
line they're like you like video games
right smith he's like yeah i love video
games put him in the chair and he's just
having to look through all that
wait did do you remember your army
recruiter call in high school
no you can get one of those i mean if i
did i probably just hung up
oh i remember the guy calling and i told
him like i just picked the hardest [ __ ]
ever he's like if you join the army
would you be like i just went sniper
and i remember him being like oh
i feel like it's kind of like a jury
duty thing where you got to just say
exactly what they don't want to hear
like wait so when do i get the guns yeah
when and do can you promise that i'll be
able to shoot someone actually they'd
probably really like that
huh oops well i'm glad i never joined
[Laughter]
anyway
hell yeah well there's hugh hefner
tommy lee
brendan fraser of the decade woman or
something like that
so what do you think about this category
this guy most apt to fall on forehead
and still get up and do it again
like that oh man brandon was still sad
then yeah poor guy
he's also he's a national treasure just
from the mummy that was such a great
movie brendan what what category are you
excited for i don't know guy most likely
to fall down the stairs and get divorced
and hit his forehead he said
he's a very specific body his head maybe
he was self-conscious because his
forehead looked pretty sweet
the ballsiest kat von d and it's between
linkin park and foo fighters and i'm
hoping it's foo fighters we'll see
i love the categories i love that
they're
not really very pc i like that they just
call it as it is and
you know catered to guys
yeah
dude so cool that trump's [ __ ]
campaign was the same one that spiked tv
the yeah like it's like the same
campaign ethos yeah so trump saw this
and was like dude i can work with this
great idea yeah i can work with this man
i like that he's not afraid to call
minorities out on their [ __ ]
these are categories that go as guys we
actually talk about who is the hottest
milf who is the biggest badass
show that caters to [ __ ] yeah no no
yeah
i love it dude i love the contrast of
that what guys do talk about and then it
goes to [ __ ] uh mclovin guys
okay
here's the theoretical who do you think
is the hottest milk and you can't say
jerry's mom because you know we all we
[ __ ] jerry's mom we all know that she's
hot dude stop sorry you'd [ __ ] your mom
okay yeah but still i don't think she
should be part of the category okay okay
fair
all right guys
which
which
marginalized community do you think
shouldn't be able to vote
just a cool
amazing group of people and i mean that
genuinely or i wouldn't still be working
with them after all these years and i'm
grateful to have another show in
addition to what i've been doing um
they're just awesome fun great people
who work hard and like they do it well
spike's awesome
hey there's chucky's let's have a
women's choice awards
you can be in charge of that
that is exactly what you would expect
him to say yeah russell brand yeah i
think it's sexist well that is it from
another red carpet event
that is it for another red carpet event
stay tuned for the guys toys awards oh
you know it's like tv
damn
she would write a movie about a guy who
wants to get back to uh
i don't know the the the
the time the part of the timeline where
we were at our peak of innocence
and i feel like you can pinpoint it to
like that horse yeah
can you fart so hard your balls explode
by innocence do you mean people just
sort of just being naive yeah nobody had
a you know it was six years past 9 11
where we kind of felt like all right you
know that's in the rear view
none of us are really crazy about this
war that we got going on but you know
we're still just living our lives we've
got our islamophobia's kind of tapered
off a little bit yeah it's tapered off
um
google and amazon and all that [ __ ]
wasn't nearly as in control of the world
as it as it was it was controlled by
networks like spike tv back then yeah
and the banks how it should be yeah the
banks the telecommunications companies
the cable companies yeah i love that
bank of america i've said it before but
i'll say it again it is shortened as
bofa bofa
both of these if i if i were a banker
and i were offered jobs
that paid higher at different banks i
would turn them down in favor of both
there was a really popular
counter-strike team
called called bofa and but they ran it
as bank of america that's fun yeah but
it never hit me till later that it was
like
[Music]
you